ahead of another week of NHS walkouts
the health secretary visited a hospital
in London
there he was confronted by a mother
whose three-year-old has cystic fibrosis
and has been on a long waiting list for
care we have some brilliant experts
um and they'll be in work to the Bone
you know and actually the level of care
they provide is amazing but they're not
being able to provide it in the way they
want to provide it because the
resourcing's not there the damage that
you're doing to to families like myself
is terrible because it was Agony for us
for family waiting for that call and
preparing our children
for that sister and her hospital visit
so then for then it to be canceled Sarah
Pennington old says the health secretary
promised more money it's frustrating to
hear them say that's why we've
prioritized it in the Autumn budget
because it's just such a line that they
that they kind of have and they bring
out all the time and and actually they
put money in but then they draw it out
in other ways
on Tuesday NHS nurses will return to the
picket line in industrial action that
could continue until summer the
government has understood to be asking
for fresh talks with the unions but
refuses to commit to nurses pay demands
of a five percent raise plus inflation a
19 pay demand Which is far in excess of
what most of your viewers themselves
were receiving is not affordable so
we've got to get that bonus right
between what is the right thing to do on
pay and what is the right thing to do in
terms of getting the the pandemic
backlogs down and really focusing in on
the needs of patients this week
ambulance staff also walk out
teachers have confirmed strikes in
January and an action that will affect
Christmas travel border Force strike
over and after the Christmas break along
with other civil service star
like in Liverpool here Department of
work and pension staff want better pay
and work conditions our members of visit
and food banks were getting
um queries about our hardship fund
Christmas this Christmas is going to be
really really difficult for many many of
our members for these staff as for those
in the NHS ministers say the door for
talks is open but that their pay demands
in this economy are simply unaffordable
Sky News